après avoir remporté son procès en
diffamation contre robert hurd l'actrice
a été reconnu coupable coupable de
diffamation elle a été condamnée à
verser 15 millions de dollars de
dommages et intérêts johnny depp a
désormais décidé de s'occuper lui de
profiter pleinement de ses vacances
d'été et quand johnny ne joue pas les
pirates des caraïbes il aime faire
quelques accords de guitare
avant de retrouver les plateaux de
cinéma l'acteur a prévu de jouer le 14
juillet prochain sur la scène du
festival guitare en scène en haute
savoie en compagnie du rockeur jeff beck
d'autres dates sont programmées comme le
festival jardin sonore ou encore
l'olympia le 25 juillet prochain alors
johnny depp programmé en tant que
guitariste à un festival en france cet
été est-ce trop tôt
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors est-ce qu'on a la part belle à
[ __ ]
question que je pose aux téléspectateurs
et avoue itron inc a manqué tout le
début par cette histoire je crois en pas
cette haine contre en berne mais vrai
mais ça l'aurait survolé on a confondu
tout le monde quand on le personnage
qu'on aime bien et ça avec l'homme et je
suis scandalisée alors c'est ce que la
vie contient
la femme de johnny da elle a dit elle ne
prend pas la décision des jurés
personnellement elle les comprend presse
caporal johnny depp faisait appel à des
témoins qui seraient ses employés donc
en fait est qu'ils étaient payés si vous
avez vu ça va passer mais bien sûr alors
moi je vous dis je suis mais scandalisé
jeu mais la justice a tranché pas juste
et ça c'est comme le jambon il a été a
été sous l'emprise de ce monsieur qui
est une grande star il joue mieux nantis
crois moi tu crois pas on allait très
bien que si on n'y a rien d un paradis
après accord après qu'il ait un jugement
j'ai des choses et le ballet sa part
année a dit que de mal a dit que du bien
de lui alors elle a dit qu'elle avait eu
des problèmes avec joe le taxi
c'était un peu plus tôt succès d'accord
mais excusez moi ce monsieur c'est un
déchet il se doit
je suis d
désolé je suis scandalisée de postes
d'ordonner que
vous parlez très ferme et vous mes
parents étaient dans leur chambre
pendant longtemps mais aux
teams and in the line avec un dow jones
à cette voie
j'ai pas été raté cavaillé ses palaces
et
réglées par la célébrité non non ce
n'était pas du tout
affaibli quelque chose a répondu
pas décidé quand on est connu on est on
prend beaucoup plus cher tout ce qu'on
est et me dont les justices bien sûr y'a
rien bah alors dit je deviens folle tu
verras
je suis scandalisée de la photonique et
monique pas scander tous les mensonges
que la sortie du pont pierre aimé et lui
qui importe c'est un procès nous ont
sortis des deux mentions gagner tu peux
me dire noir sur blanc sec antibois
quand ils se droguent pas au point où
avec elle
je ne vais pas chez lui j'en sais rien
moi chez toi non plus tu vis pas chez
elle non plus pourquoi l'abandon de
canaliser mais je n'ai rien fait l'amour
à ça
[Rires]
et
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai t'as raison c'est charlie et
la chocolaterie
mais non mais s'ils abandonnent les
paras qu'il va faire un gros coup un
goût un sale coup à vanessa paradis le
corps lors du concert n'en soyez pas
qu'il a fait une reprise de joe le taxi
allez jo le vtc
sans déconner il est en train de faire
des sales combines en mai dernier n'a
pas eu ça mais moi c'est moi ni même
d'en quête m'a bien sûr monique et jury
de cette quelque sorte à johnny depp tu
connais même pas chanteur français tu va
nous dire et là elle a fait une audience
catastrophique
elle a eu des avocats qui ridiculise et
bien sûr un lit de la justice et pas
celle que vous voulez de plus bien sûr
est ce que vous voyez qu'il pense à la
justice même 65 justice monique g g
vient de dire quelle est sa mission
c'est jean poulin repris le débit des
risques en l et es les meetings depuis
le début elle est formalisée titulo
dialogue subtil c'est que je connais de
l'ariane et un suivi est rare
jamais pris l'avion
nan mais tu connais encore toi ne fais
pas chier en or
s'il vous plaît ne voyais même pas la
massachusetts
que tu connais tu connais rien n'a rien
le doyen des stones nominatives on sait
même pas pourquoi tu es là que c'est du
pur
c'est calme toi je te plaît arrête de
parler roma
monétaire règle et tais toi tu te fais
du val
une j'ai du mal
[Applaudissements]
j'ai tout écrit c'est mon colis
vous dites n'importe quoi tout le monde
tape sur les ovaires
tirer
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est
bien
le
referee que pardon mais monique est en
train de se fourvoyer c'est pas parce
que je suis en maudit grog qu'il est
forcément coupable en a bien sûr lundi
n'a pas de quoi paniquer zellige 8
passes au thoronet
chetout
le vif et la libération de la parole en
tant que femme elle ne mérite pas qu'on
monte il a bien sûr fait beaucoup de mal
surtout mois l'annulation de la parole
parce qu'elle a menti sur tout a bien
sûr fait le problème de mental au même
prix michel est ce que vous anxieux
couleur menthe à ça arrête de marmonner
dans ton dans tulle puis deux heures
[Musique]
nous allons faire des pétards et là
on ne juge pas juste par sa vie qu'il
diffamation uniquement ça c'est clair en
foot qu'il est je ne sais quoi parce que
j'ai même pas ce que c'est qu'un style
si tu sais rien su rien pourquoi depuis
c'est pas moi c'est vrai que c'est sa
réaction et après tout à
ma peine elle avait ouvert la bouche je
suis désolé c'est un délit de sale
gueule parce que tel
il faut qu'ils en aient une ville
masquer une sale gueule pour toi
n'importe quoi n'importe où monique
rené cros l'a fait du bien vivre à nixon